this is what I find interesting like so
you were actually about to quit acting
right before you got shit's creek right
yes just before shit's creek things were
quite Bleak
um my house had just burnt down I had
like three dollars in my bank account
things were
I hadn't worked in close to two years oh
and I had just blown uh my very first
screen test like blown it blown it blown
it blown it and I was I found myself
crying in the Pacific Ocean a very
snotty cry and the universe was like
don't do this anymore this is not for
you and but then two days later I got
the audition for shit's creek that is I
I really
I love that you tell this story though
because a lot of people when until then
I think it's really cool because B I do
have friends that are actors and it's a
very hard job it's either you're like
really winning or you're just like
really gone like you know it's kind of
and same thing in music but it's it's
just really cool that you're open about
it like because everybody goes to those
moments where you're like oh my gosh
like is this or should I move on or
should I do this and I love that you're
open about it I also love that you're
hilarious and one of my favorite shows
of all time but
um Annie after your audition you your
hair color almost lost you the job
correct yeah that's crazy since you know
you can dye your hair you can yeah but
um my sweet huge my sweet Eugene Levy
um he had a hard time wrapping his head
around that because in they did like an
initial presentation pilot for the show
yeah and in the pilot uh Abby Elliott
who's Chris Elliott's daughter and he's
amazing she played Alexis yeah um and
she's very blonde and luckily she's like
a very successful actor who was too busy
to do the show so I owe her my job in my
life
um but yeah Eugene was so set in the in
the blonde thing and was like ah wow
like Dan caldman was like we found
Alexis and Eugene was like but uh
you know she's has a brown hair and
they're impression
and Dan was like Dad we can just dye her
hair like it's not that big a deal and
finally Dan went out and and I it was
like a happy medium we've done like a
this situation which Eugene could deal
with yeah that's awesome and God is in
the details I guess Eugene
um so it is the show is ending did we
all emotional like at the end because I
imagine when you have a great cast like
that it's like sucks when it ends yeah
yeah it was I mean it was five of the
best years of my life but
um I kept my emotion to myself for the
most part and like you know kept it in
the realm of my shower at home but again
uh whose show you know has been the show
runner of the show uh at table reads
like the last three table reads would
start doing this thing that we started
calling the noise which is like kind of
like this
and it was like his face was eating
itself and it would just be him trying
to keep his emotion in so so desperately
um and we'd make fun of him for it of
course totally as a friend does yeah
um and he would get so angry that I was
like more or less emotionless but then
cut to our last day of work and my last
day of shooting and I am just puddle oh
the messiest gnarliest looking I know I
wish I could like Rachel McAdams cry
from The Notebook but it's just not in
the card it's not reality it's not
that's not real she is really good at
that very good yeah it just looks like
oh no are you surprised with how popular
that's not my entire crew loves that
song they want this song
uh thank you
um this song well because you wrote it I
wrote it with two of my best buds yeah
who are musicians so they did like the
you know music yes um and I wrote the
lyrics and we all secretly secretly we
knew it had to be funny yeah but we all
were like oh we want to write a banger
so badly like it's
it's have you ever heard this
heard this we don't heard it today
actually it was the first time likewise
yeah I can't get out of my head and I'm
very happy that I can't get out of there
yeah yes it's so clever be careful when
you're driving later
it really gets it gets to you how did
you come up with the dance moves because
that's what makes it epic as well
um I so I came up with the dance moves
but shockingly by myself
um in my trailer about 20 minutes before
we shot and I called Sarah levian who
plays Twila on the show and I was like
Sarah watch this what do you think and
she was like oh that's that's really
really bad and I was like nice you're
like
[Music]
okay well earlier I asked if you would
sing a little bit of Alexis with me you
want to do it
[Applause]
I hope I remember this oh God gotta get
my arm oh you're awesome
[Music]
are you ready
let's do it what's that I'm a
Lamborghini I'm a Hollywood star I'm a
little bit tipsy when I drive my car I'm
expensive sushi I'm a kitchen shot
I'm a little bit single even when I'm
not
I'm a little bit
I'm a classic Bronco I'm a Texas time
I'm a whole lot of tipsy when I drink
fine wine I got like 20 jobs and I talk
a lot I'm a whole lot married my man's
so hot
I'm a whole lot
[Music]
hide your diamonds
[Applause]
oh my God
okay everybody knows this but your dad
is Eugene Levy and y'all co-star
together but I'm just wondering because
he's quite the comedian like did he ever
embarrass you as a kid 100 yeah that's
the tricky thing about having a dad who
is who is funny is you know when you get
in fights with your parents growing up
usually you can just sort of buffer that
because your dad isn't doing weird
voices and characters back to you to try
and get you to break the anger
um which is what was happening with me
so he would sort of push it time and
time again and do like either a voice or
a character when things got really rough
and I would crack and be so mad that I
laughed because I was really upset that
I was grounded or something we just had
Annie on here actually too and I mean
she is so much fun but she said you
threw a good brunch I can't make
anything but breakfast foods I only love
breakfast great but I mean what did she
bring to your brother so I would when we
were shooting the show I would host
these brunches so Annie shows up one
time
because she felt bad that she was coming
empty-handed
um and stopped by a KFC on the way to my
brunch
showed up with a bucket of chicken I had
been slaving away since 7 30 in the
morning
I had baking to do and she shows up with
this bucket of KFC
my food was still on the table the
bucket was empty everybody it was like
people were just about to try my
pancakes and then saw the chicken and
were like no I'm going for this and
that's how it went my own brunch she
stole your thunder I know can I just
talk about the fact that a little bit of
Lexus is my favorite it was my musical
director's idea he's the one that got me
at her show and I it was my favorite
thing I've literally ever done in my
life basically watched I've done a lot
of cool things but that is my favorite
the clip hit the internet I watched it I
let out a scream that could be heard
across the ocean it was the single
greatest piece of Television I think
I've ever seen I and that's including us
talking right now so that's really
generous of me
I love it you know what on the bounce
the bounce is a crisis ever it was
really hard though to like for a person
that's you know I'm supposed to have
rhythm so it was really hard I kept she
kept laughing at me because she was like
can you look more Awkward I'm like I'm
really trying I was like I was I was
really trying but anyway you make me
laugh and now you're quitting and
whatever so I'm just kidding I'm just
kidding so um is it a hard thing that
it's ending though for real oh God I
mean I can't I can't truly Express how
devastating it was to say goodbye to
these people I mean we are such a
close-knit family I love the show so
deeply you literally our family though
in many cases We are family
um and I think I've just given my whole
heart and soul to the show so knowing
that it was ending I was a mess and I'm
like a crier generally speaking me too
and Annie speaking of
didn't cry at all
table reads the last table read of our
entire episode dry as a bone is she dead
and I'm thinking to myself is she dead
inside what's going on the last scene we
shot of our entire show she loses it
yeah and cannot stop crying through the
entire rehearsal to the point where I'm
like we have a show to make yeah now is
not the time of all the time to start
crying now is the worst one
um but it was very funny because I'm
like will she ever break and then she
broke big time oh I love it I miss
shit's creek do you miss it because it
was such a great cast I actually do I do
I do miss it I miss I miss doing it you
know when we actually rap the series I I
said to myself
what are we doing this this could be
going on but it was the right decision
yeah I mean maybe it was such a I was so
obsessed well you never want to take a
chance that you're going to go into
another season then it's just not going
to be quite as good you know and I get
it but at the same time mad whatever
um Andy do you ever watch old episodes
like when they come on well now that the
show is in syndication you know when
you're kind of Channel flipping I will
sometimes see
the show on the air and to be honest I
can watch it now
as if I wasn't really in it
wow you know I mean I can actually watch
it as a television episode just to see
how everything holds up you know yeah
because when you're doing a show you
have a tendency sometimes to maybe
only look at yourself when you're
looking at the show I don't know if you
ever kind of go through that at all but
you find yourself focused on yourself
quite a bit just to see how am I doing
how am I you know how do I look in the
scene well that's great I mean this is
great I'm holding up my end of the scene
and then the more you kind of you know
see it
during the editing process and
everything else the more you're looking
at an episode then you you kind of
notice everything else right but it's
the it's an actor's thing I think I
don't honestly know if it's possible for
an actor to look at himself in a scene
and look at the scene without looking at
himself I mean I was going to say that
yeah what well it is amazing though to
point out though editors are amazing
because after doing the voice like it's
one of those things where you you're in
it so you like you said you're in it
you're doing your thing but then you
watch it back and how they edit it
together these people are so gifted at
what they do they make you look funnier
yeah they make you like they make the
show better I'm just like wait that's
not how it happened what I was like yeah
they make us look way better because
there's too many moments you can
remember as being kind of bad moments
that I wish I could take back yeah and
yet you don't see it they're good when
it's in the final product right because
they've they have snipped it out yeah
good I no I know I God bless them um so
why why did you like really
um why did you want to write a book on
the show you know our fans are when it
comes to shit's creek knowledge they are
they are the most intelligent they're
like Mensa they're they they know every
single thing about the show so we wanted
to give them a book that they would find
interesting
and things in the book that they
actually would find interesting and and
and not necessarily you know know
everything about yeah right and and on
social media over the years when we were
doing our show
a lot of great stuff would come out in
social media the you know people would
be Dr painting you know things and
caricatures and settings and scenes yeah
and we used a lot of that fan art in the
uh in the book as as an acknowledgment
to the people who actually went Above
and Beyond in in helping to you know
promote the show that they loved and
it's the actors talking about their
characters and talking about their
favorite scenes in the show and
um oh God everything you wanted to know
about moira's wigs and it's I mean
they're it's all it's all in there and
we're we're hoping that
um that the fans really really love it I
imagine that be so proud to it's so cool
of you to involve them like you know to
have them be a part of it as well that's
so cool well they were such a big part
of of the success of our show because
they they you know social media when
people take to what you do and they're
so passionate about it it can turn
things around it can really turn things
around they can't stop talking about it
and it became infectious it really it
really helped spread the word so this
was like a Little Love Letter too to our
fans
um well speaking of wigs you brought it
up um the book has this picture of you
which is fantastic
so what's going on here and how many
drugs were you on
well that that was uh take I mean it was
taken on our after we wrapped the series
after our very last scene doing the show
which was outside at the uh Rosebud
Motel
and we we finished we popped some
champagne yeah
and
I was feeling rather Merry
and well one of moira's wigs was being
kind of passed around one of the
trailers at that point and we were all
kind of you know in there together
telling stories and congratulating each
other and crying and saying goodbye
and somebody put the wig on me and I I
it felt so good
I do feel like you should have an
English accent and you should be stoned
I think it would be a really great
character for something
um well Dan wrote some things on the
show just to tease you right what was
one I heard how to do something maybe
with your hair
yeah well
yeah there was one I love this episode
that's that's the one okay I'm a little
picky about my hair uh and and it's not
you know it's not vanity it's it's not
vanity it's just really tough hair
to do you know for me I mean I mean I'm
looking at it now and it's like it's got
a little
curl in the front I can't do anything
about it so I I'm I'm kind of touchy
about you know just getting my hair it
takes a while to get my hair to look the
way I think it should yes he wrote an
episode called the drip where I'm lying
in bed and all night a drip has been
dripping on my head
and I wake up soaked and I you know when
I read the scene I said oh Dad really
like it can't drip anywhere else except
on my hair I mean yeah okay okay I'll do
it we should we we were shooting the
scene
and I take a break and I look in that
little hand mirrors how can I borrow a
little mirror and I checked the mirror
and I'm going uh okay it's it's all
right I think I can live with this and
then I hear a voice saying I think it
should be more wet
that was dead which is Daniel
that was Daniel
uh and I said really he said yeah I
don't think it's going to play unless it
it's really got to look like it's wet
this is for not getting him something at
Christmas yeah this is it's from
something and I could I could never to
this day track exactly what it was but
uh we did the scene and he got such a
kick out of it honestly I mean I got as
much fun watching him
watching me being as miserable as I was
doing the scene uh but it all worked for
the scene and I got it and I knew why
the hair had to be wet so I went ahead
and did it he leaned in I leaned that's
a real man yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you